auf der a7 steckt electric meister paul
engelbrecht zeit stunden denn fest es
uns jetzt zugeschaltet herr engelbrecht
seit stunden stehen sie auf der autobahn
und es geht gar nichts mehr beschreiben
sie uns ihre situation und wie geht es
ihnen dabei also ich kann ihnen sagen
ich bin heute früh insgesamt war ich
zwölf ein viertel stunden gestanden ohne
dass ich etwas gehört haben mehrere
anrufe bei der polizei oder bei den
autobahnmeistereien ohne jeglichen
erfolgt die polizei hat gleich aufgelegt
das habe ich noch nie erlebt es hatten
sich niemand gehört bei neun grad - ich
bin rausgegangen da waren kinder vor mir
in dem auto die haben geschrien vor
kälte weil die haben kein diesel mehr
cup im audio decoder paar minuten immer
an machen
es war eigentlich eher katastrophenfall
was da passiert ist und ich wundere mich
ich habe bis zum schluss nicht ein
einziges räumfahrzeug sehen ich vermute
die sind alle im home office bei den
autobahnmeistereien so eine sauerei
zwölf einheimischen die polizei hätte
nichts dabei gehabt wenn sie ihr
gegangen wenn er hat uns einfach aus
geleitet aus dem ganzen unglück weiter
ausbauen lassen
wer kein thema gewesen wir waren
zwischen großenmoor branche und zwischen
dem hattenbacher dreieck gelegen und da
war mit 12 1 viertelstunden vor welche
die war noch länger dort standen die
wahl zwischen 30 und 40 stunden ohne
irgendetwas zu erfahren von der polizei
ohne dass jemand durch gekommen ist
haben uns einmal eine heiße getränke
gehen wir waren ohne essen ohne trinken
ohne allem die ok für die männer geht es
ja noch die trümmer in die seite gehen
aber die frauen die haben wenig leid
getan also wie man sowas lassen kann um
ebenso wie den leuten umgehen auf der
straße da muss ich sagen das sind
eigentlich die falschen neugart wenn die
polizei natürlich bei 25 grad zu hause
bleibt und in ihrer wohnung sitzen oder
ihren ihre amtsstuben sitzen und verkehr
nicht um leiden oder rückwärts raus
gelassen hätten einvernehmlich kein
problem gewesen wenn man innerhalb
teilweise stunde alle draußen gewesen
wenn die pkws rückwärts gefahren werden
nein wenn wir sie stehen bleiben neben
der lkw ist und haben nichts machen
können und das ganze zwölf
viertelstunden es ist eigentlich nur
noch peinlich für diese leute wurden
agieren
wie kamen sie denn aus dieser situation
wieder raus aus der ganzen situation
rausgekommen in dem der verkehr ganz
langsam dann nach 12 ein viertel stunden
wieder geöffnet wurde also für mich zu
ärgern würde stunden wieder geöffnet
wurde und ich bin dann die zehn
kilometer bis zum hattenbacher dreieck
und dann richtung gießen jetzt weiter
gefahren
aber für mich ist das eine katastrophe
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe
ganz ganz wichtigen termin gehabt und
wenn kontinuität einhalten der termine
ist ist natürlich schrecklich für mich
so was zu machen ich bin selber als
geschäftsmann ich bin gutachter und
sachverständige und habe natürlich
drücke der mit mehreren leuten nicht
einhalten können
okay was ist wenn schnee fällt ist ja
kein problem ich habe nichts dagegen
aber es schlimme war dass die polizei zu
faul war uns eigentlich raus zu leiden
aus dem ganzen einfach auf der autobahn
drehen lassen zehn kilometer zurück
fahren auf der autobahn von hinten
anfangen war überhaupt kein problem
gewesen darüber die meisten auf und
darüber reden sie alle auf die autobahn
waren alle haben gesagt sie haben so was
ähnliches noch nie erlebt und ich auch
nicht muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen dass
ich ein schneechaos hat tatsächlich auch
haben weite teile deutschlands noch nie
erlebt wir können ihnen wünschen dass
sie jetzt nach diesem chaos in eine
ruhige nacht staaten danke dass sie sich
für uns zeit genommen haben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren